very chilly chilly morning out there and
you've got to move
hopefully you've moved your sweaters and
jackets to the front of the closet
and you're ready to pull them out this
morning it's cold out there we've got
clear skies
it's been a little dust too because
these winds have been so
ferocious and the air is super super
dried out
dew points are in the single digits
temperatures in the low 40s
but it feels a lot colder than that
we've had some ferocious gusts
to near 60 miles an hour in laughlin
that was last night just before midnight
red rock 50 plus it's not a great day
for
hiking or boating i would say please
just leave that till
tomorrow or the day after when we start
to warm up a little bit and the winds
calm down
these are the actual feels like
temperatures
the temperatures are in the low 40s but
anthem you feel like 29 this morning
sunrise mountain feels like 35 aliante
you feel like freezing
and centennial hills it feels like 30
degrees in your neighborhood this
morning
it feels like teens up there at kyle
canyon actual temperatures are in the
thirties red rock parrot you've both got
wind out there
boulder city bumping around high wind
warnings for boulder city the lake
all along the river down to laughlin
until nine o'clock tonight our high is
only going to be 59
76 is normal remember we were around at
90 last week
sunrise 6 58 but that will be an hour
earlier when we fall back
to standard time this weekend don't
forget your clocks halloween night
before you go to bed cold air snow rain
yeah all that went east it missed us we
didn't get any of it i'm sorry
and tonight we got freeze warnings for
areas outside of las vegas
kingman prim searchlight indian springs
mesquite you're all looking at freezing
maybe even some upper 20s when these
winds back off
and that cold sets in with clear skies
we'll get back to 60s tomorrow
70s through the rest of the week even 80
degrees gonna be a beautiful halloween
for the kiddos on saturday our